bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette petite vidéo où aujourd'hui
on va se faire un petit tp d'évolution
humaine avec des crânes qui sont devant
vous ici alors aucun de ces crânes ne
sombre a évidemment ce sont des
répliques c'est à dire que ce sont des
copies de véritables crâne
évidemment je ne me promène pas avec des
animaux morts et des fossiles comme ça
dans la nature
mais ces répliques sont absolument
fidèle au crâne d'origine
alors on commence la série de
l'évolution humaine par les singes donc
les singes qui sont représentés ici par
le babouin donc pourquoi le babouin est
un singe est pas un humain est bien pour
plusieurs raisons déjà la longueur du
museau donc les babouins ont un museau
extrêmement longue comparée au reste du
crâne un cerveau relativement petit de
l'ordre de 200 à 300 cm cube et ils ont
ces énormes canines sur tous les mâles
qui les distingue bien des êtres humains
modernes et ici vous voyez quand on
ouvre la mâchoire on voit le palais le
palais qui forme du fait de ces deux
c'est énorme et canines vous voyez les
canines sont les coins d'un rectangle
qui est très visible chez les singes
donc ici chez le babouin on a aussi
quelque chose qui s'appelle le
progressisme alors le promu nautisme ça
va de pair avec le long museau
c'est en fait tu n'y as tu viens de
mâchoires donc prognathe isme c'est la
mâchoire qui vient à l'avant en fait
donc ici vous voyez que les canines du
de la mâchoire inférieure viennent
devant les canines de la mâchoire
supérieure c'est quelque chose qui est
très différent évidemment quand vous
regardez un être humain par exemple donc
si vous me regardez moi mais canine mais
canine viennent de dessus viennent
devant les canines du de soumah s'est
complètement l'opposé en fait chez les
ch et la plupart des autres animaux
singes inclus et ça se voit très bien
sur l'usure des canines
donc si vous regardez sur la mâchoire
ici on voit bien la facette d'usure que
la canine supérieur imprime sur la
canine inférieur et ça se voit très bien
aussi
ça se voit très bien aussi ici sur la
canine supérieur vous voyez cette
facette d'usure et très midi
sur les canines supérieur et elle est
faite par la canine inférieur donc même
si vous n'avez pas les deux mâchoires
vous pouvez quand même faire l'hypothèse
de proxénétisme
ça marche très bien donc voilà pourquoi
le bois ne sont pas considérés comme des
humains le par contre ce sont bel et
bien des primates
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont les fameuses
orbite kiffa qui font face vers l'avant
donc une vision binoculaire et le nombre
d' à sisyphe donc vous voyez ici elles
sont perdues mais on voit toujours les
les trous pour les incisives vous avez
une deux incisives de chaque côté ça
c'est typiquement primates
on passe ensuite au gorille alors le
gorille est un peu plus proche des êtres
humains c'est un grand singe et non pas
un simple singes comme le babouin
donc c'est un grand singe est ce qui le
rapproche des êtres humains mais déjà
vous pouvez voir ne serait-ce que la
longueur du museau la longueur du museau
qui est beaucoup plus court chez le
gorille vous avez aussi le développement
de ce bourg les supras orbitaire qui est
typique des grands singes vous voyez que
je chez ceux babouins qui est pourtant
un mal le bourrelet sus orbitaire n'est
pas très développée donc là vous avez le
développement de ce très très épais pour
les suces orbitaire qui est typique des
grands singes c'est en fait ce n'est pas
un morceau d'os en fait c'est
complètement creuses on peut voler ce
solitaire il est connecté aux sinus et
donc si vous le casser ou si vous
l'ouvrez ou si vous faites une
radiographie vous verrez que il y a
asinus à l'intérieur donc c'est un
développement osseux mais qui est creux
à l'intérieur et qu'on voit toujours
chez les êtres humains donc c'est pour
ça que quand vous avez un rhume ou une
sinusite vous avez mal au front ce n'est
pas ce que vous avez encore un bourrelet
support orbitaire simplement chez l'être
humain le bourrelet sus orbitaire il a
été complètement recouvert par le
développement du cerveau qui est venu
par dessus mais on y reviendra donc chez
les au gorille vous avez toujours les
grosses canine surtout chez ceux mali si
vous avez toujours les canines du
dessous qui viennent à l'avant des
canines du dessus vous avez toujours le
palais qui est bien avec temps guller et
vous avez cette crête sagittale qui est
très très très développée chez le
gorille elle l'était un peu moins chez
le babouin ici donc on en a pas parlé
mais elle était déjà là et chez le
gorille mâle surtout elles sont très
développés alors sécrète cette crête
sagittale c'est un poids d'à tâche pour
le muscle mastic ateurs qui vient
s'attacher ici qui passe ensuite dans ce
trou et bien sa tâche et là sur la
mâchoire donc c'est un énorme muscles
l'instigateur et les gorille mâle en ont
un plus gros que les gorille femelle
parce qu il aime bien se taper dessus
les gorilles mal en tout cas il aime
bien essayer de se faire peur et donc
plus ils ont des gros muscles
instigateurs plus ils ont plus ils ont
de chances de conquérir des femelles et
de gagner des territoires donc ce
gorille mâle s'éteint c'est l'exemple
typique du grand singe et les grands
singes ils ont cette particularité aussi
qui les rapproche des êtres humains
vous voyez quand on regarde le palais
vous voyez ce petit trou ici c'est le
foramen à sisyphe voilà donc le foramen
à sisyphe c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve aussi chez l'être humain
moderne
il n'est pas très joli mais évidemment
c'est une copie c'est un moulage mais
vous le pouvez le voir ici le foramen à
sisyphe voilà et ce faux ramène à
sisyphe il n'est pas lâcher le
chez le babouin chez le babouin vous
avez de grandes fenêtres palatine et non
pas un petit foramen incisif
donc ça c'est un autre caractère que
nous partageons avec les grands singes
et se forme et se fera mais non on le
retrouve évidemment aussi chez lush
attendent donc maintenant qu'est ce qui
fait que le gorille n'est pas considéré
comme un être humain donc je vous ai
déjà parlé des canines je vous ai déjà
parlé de la forme du palais il y a
évidemment la position du foramen magnum
donc ici vous voyez le foramen magnum
qui est situé à l'arrière du crâne
donc qui indique que la colonne
vertébrale rentrait de cette façon à
l'arrière du crâne donc horizontalement
ce qui veut dire que le gorille et
quadrupèdes
alors que si vous prenez un crâne
d'êtres humains modernes
encore une fois et bien ce crâne d'êtres
humains modernes le faut chez ce crâne
d'êtres humains modernes le foramen
magnum l'entrée de la moelle épinière
dans le dans le crâne se situe sous le
crâne
donc ici ça vous indique que la colonne
vertébrale se placer de cette façon là
donc la bipédie ce qui va différencier
le gorille de l'être humain
essentiellement c'est la position du
foramen magnum qui indique qu'une
position quadrupèdes pour le gorille et
bipèdes pour l'être humain est ici ça se
voit très très bien en fait vous si vous
prenez un le gorille et que vous mettez
le crâne de dos comme ça et que vous
mettez le crâne humain de dos comme ça
ici vous pouvez voir le foramen magnum
là vous ne pouvez pas le voir parce que
justement il est situé sous le crâne et
pas à l'arrière alors on entre
maintenant dans la lignée des hominidés
où les hominiens si vous préférez donc
la ligne équivalent ultime ultime en
finir avec le l'être humain homo sapiens
alors cette lignée évidemment elle est
sûre simplifiée ici un évidemment ça ne
se résume pas à une simple ligne et
rappelez-vous la buissonne ans de
l'évolution humaine mais évidemment on
ne peut pas tout montrer durant à un tp
il va bien falloir sélectionné quelques
exemples parlants donc voici cette
sélection d'exemples et on commence
cette sélection d'exemples justement par
le parent trope alors le parent trap il
a vécu il y à entre deux et un million
d'années donc c'est un exemple
relativement des récents d'êtres humains
alors pourquoi je les milla et bien tout
simplement parce que il a beaucoup de
caractère primitif se pare en europe et
par beaucoup de ses caractères il évoque
toumaï donc le fameux sahel entre opus
qui est lui l'être humain le lot mini le
plus ancien qu'on connaisse qui a vécu
il ya 7 millions d'années alors qu'est
ce qui fait que le parent trap ressemble
à toumaï et bien c'est ça crée de
sagittale part entre up est un des seuls
hominiens avec toumaï à avoir une crête
sagittale marché tout maïs et la
rétention d'un caractère primitif mais
chez le parent trope c'est parce que il
est adapté à une nourriture une
nourriture herbivores donc il a une très
très grande crête sagittale pour les
muscles l'instigateur il a aussi de très
grandes arcades du gal pour les muscles
massé terre donc les muscles
zygomatiques tout s'adonnant à sa
mâchoire une grande puissance mastic
attristé vous pouvez voir la taille des
dents qui est absolument gigantesque
exactement d'ailleurs comme chez le
gorille donc on est sûr on est sur des
animaux qui sont définitivement fait
pour écraser de la fibre végétale et le
parent trope a évidemment un petit
museau qui est aussi un caractère
relativement primitive vous voyez que ça
fasse et légèrement projeter vers
l'avant donc il avait un petit museau un
peu comme le gorille et come to my il a
aussi des caractères qui sont plus
humains
le prochain le principal étant la
réduction de la de la canine
alors là de quelle est la canine
vous me direz parce qu elles se
ressemblent toutes ses dents et bien
tout simplement vous comptez deux dents
rappelez-vous les primates n'ont que
deux incisives de chaque côté donc 1 2
voilà la canine et de l'autre côté 1 2
voilà la cani donc la canine est très
réduite comme chez toumaï ce qui indique
ce qui est un caractère humain par
excellence mais surtout il y a la
position du foramen magnum qui comme
chez toumaï est en position ventrale
donc pareil vous prenez le gorille vous
prenez votre crâne de parents trope vous
le regardez par derrière
chez part entre hop on ne voit pas le
foramen magnum parce qu'il est situé
sous le crâne alors que chez le gorille
on voit le foramen magnum parce qu'il
est situé à l'arrière du crâne donc
position quadrupèdes
et ici on a une position tout à fait
bipèdes qui est indiquée par le foramen
magnum donc même si on n'a pas tout maïs
ou la main par entre up et quand même
donne quand même une image assez
raisonnable de ce que toumaï partage
avec les autres nominés maintenant le
nominer primitif par excellence j'ai
envie de dire c'est australopithecus
donc là vous avez trois exemples
d'australopithecus présentés dans
l'ordre historique dans lequel ils ont
été découverts donc australopithecus a
vécu entre 4 et 2 millions d'années
environ
le plus ancien australopithèques étant
australopithecus adam n 6 qui a vécu il
ya 4,4 millions d'années si je ne
m'abuse
et ici ce que vous avez c'est
australopithecus africanus et
australopithecus sediba alors tout le
monde est familier généralement avec
lucy l'australopithèque us le plus connu
qui est australopithecus afarensis donc
ça c'est africanus c'est son pendant sud
africain en fait et beaucoup de gens
s'imaginent que l'uci est le plus ancien
des australopithèques ou a été du
moelleux l'australopithèque le premier
découvert donc le plus ancien
australopithèques je voulais 17,1 à
mennecy ce n'est pas afarensis
n'actionnait pas lui si tu es le premier
australopithecus découvert et bien c'est
celui là
celle australopithecus africanus
d'afrique du sud et c'est en
l'occurrence ce spécimen là qui
s'appelle l'enfant de tang du nom de la
ville où il a été découvert donc
l'enfant de tang qui représent ait
représenté par un petit crâne avec ici
ce que vous voyez sur le moulin
endocrânienne donc c'est le moulage en
fait de la cavité du cerveau je vois
même les petites veines encore imprimé
c'est assez c'est assez impressionnant
comme spécimens donc cet enfant de tang
il a été découvert en 1924 lucie elle a
été découvert dans les années 70 dont
vous voyez costra l'hôpital cus a été
découvert bien bien avant la découverte
de lucy et donc à l'époque
australopithecus africanus a été
découvert donc ce spécimen a été
découvert
on ne connaissait d'homininés que en
europe et en asie dans que néandertal
est homo erectus l'homme de java donc
cet australopithèque eu cela a été le
premier à suggérer que l'être humain
était en fait originaires d'afrique et à
l'époque évidemment personne ne voulait
croire raymond d'arte qui a été le
découvreur de ce fossile
personne ne voulait le croire parce que
tout semblait indiquer à l'époque que
l'être humain était originaire de ghazi
et surtout on avait à l'époque le fameux
l'homme de piltdown qui est dont tout le
monde avait admis que c'était une réelle
preuve de l'existence de l'origine
européenne de l'être humain donc pile
dorn s'est avéré être un faux et à côté
de ça on a levé donc plus que
australopithecus comme éventuelle source
de des êtres humains
sauf que le problème c'est que
australopithecus africanus telle que
représentée par l'enfant de tang
c'est un juvénile donc on le voit sur le
crâne ici vous voyez c'est d'anglais de
très petites incisive qui sont des
incisives de l'est et vous voyez que bah
il a qu'une seule molaires donc aller
les deux autres molaires ne sont pas
encore sorties donc le pauvre enfant de
tanguay mort très jeune et le problème
c'est que bâchée chez les primates les
juvéniles ont un air beaucoup plus
humain que les adultes donc je vous ai
pris ici par exemple un babouin juvénile
afin de vous représenter justement à
quel point les juvéniles de primates
ressemblent à des êtres humains adultes
vous avez donc le museau qui est très
très court comparé à l'adulte et vous
avez la boîte crânienne qui est très
très grosse comparé au reste du crâne et
tout ça c'est des caractères très humain
et regardez où est le faux ramène magnum
le foramen magnum et sous le crâne
exactement comme chez un être humain
donc si vous comparez à l'enfant de
tongs
vous avez exactement les mêmes types de
caractères dont gros cerveau face
à courcy et foramen magnum situé sous le
crâne donc ici chez l'enfant de tang
donc on a tous les ingrédients en fait
pour s'imaginer que l'enfant de tang
pourrait être proche des êtres humains
sur la base de ces caractères mais
évidemment les scientifiques ne sont pas
dupes et voit très bien que ces
caractères pourrait très bien être liés
à la juvénilité de de ce spécimen donc
tant qu'on n'avait pas de spécimens
adultes
eh ben on n'avait aucun moyen d'être sûr
que australopithèques us était bel et
bien relié à la lignée humaine
l'enfant de tango aurait très bien pu
grandir et devenir un individu tel que
ceux tels que ce bas - c'est-à-dire un
individu avec de très longs museaux
d'énormes canine et un foramen magnum
qui serait situé plus à l'arrière donc
donc tant qu'on avait que ce spécimen
juvénile en 1924 et là on était coincés
même en admettant que l'homme de
piltdown était un faux on était quand
même coincé on pouvait pas conclure sur
la véritable parenté d'australopithèques
us avec les êtres humains mais dans une
vingtaine d'années plus tard fut
découvert ce spécimen qui s'appelle mi6
place un seul missile souplesse était le
premier australopithèques us adultes
découvert et comme l'enfant de tang
il avait un cerveau relativement grand
par rapport à la phase un museau
relativement plus long que l'enfant de
tangue mais pas de beaucoup
ea foramen magnum définitivement placée
sous le crâne
sans oublier la petite taille des
canines conforme à l'être humain moderne
et qu'on peut deviner grâce à la petite
taille de la levée hall convoi dans le
crâne donc mis six pièces vingt ans
après l'enfant de tang a finalement
démontré que australopithèques us était
bien un proche parent des êtres humains
modernes et surtout et bien que les
australopithèques était bien à la racine
de l'évolution humaine plus primitive
que néandertal et que homo erectus et
donc a définitivement enraciné l'arbre
évolutif humains en afrique donc c'est
ce spécimen là qui a pour la première
fois démontrer l'origine africaine de
l'être humain et tous les autres
spécimens qui aurait été découvert après
sa non fait que le confirmer
et ce dernier australopithèques que vous
avez ici alors il est relativement
similaire à misys plaisent comme vous
pouvez le voir il a peut-être juste les
arcades sourcilières un peu moins
développés et les arcades du gal un peu
moins projeté sur le côté c'est
australopithecus sediba donc
australopithecus sediba contrairement à
l'uci ou a mis six pièces où l'enfant de
tang il a été découvert très récemment
en 2009 et il a cette particularité
australopithecus sediba d'avoir de
relativement petite dent pour un
australopithèque il a aussi la
particularité d'avoir un âge
relativement récent australopithecus
sediba n'a que 2 millions d'années alors
que la plupart des autres
australopithèques ont entre entre 3 et 4
millions d'années les plus récents comme
cela ayant 2 5 millions d'années donc
lui celui là est vraiment récent
l'australopithecus sediba est vraiment
récents et donc ces petites dents cédant
relativement petit et son âge
relativement récent apparemment le
placent plutôt proche du genre homo il
ya même certains certaines phylogénie
qui en font définitivement à
représentants du genre homo
le seul truc c'est qu'il a effectivement
encore un tout petit cerveau donc
beaucoup de personnes sont assez assez
frileuses à l'idée de le placer dans le
genre homo encore que des il existe des
représentants du genre homo à petit
cerveau comme homo floresiensis mais
bref pour l'instant australopithecus
sediba est toujours considéré comme
australopithèques us australopithecus
sediba est aussi toujours un
australopithèque à cause de la forme de
son palais son palais est toujours
relativement rectangulaire comme vous
pouvez le voir et ça ça va changer avec
le spécimen suivant qui est homo naledi
chez homo naledi alors quand on le place
dans la même vu que australopithecus
sediba on voit que son palais et
arrondies donc là c'est la mâchoire
inférieure mais le palet à la même forme
que la mâchoire inférieure il devient
arrondi exactement comme chez l'humain
moderne le on dit aussi que la forme est
parabolique et ça c'est un caractère
d'êtres humains qui est aussi liée à la
réduction de la dentition mais cette
fois les dents sont tellement réduites
en fait que le palais n'a plus à avoir
cette forme
rectangulaire maintenant elle est cette
forme arrondie donc au moins à l'e10 est
considéré comme un représentant du genre
homo il a une il est relativement récent
de l'ordre de seulement 200 mille ans
donc c'est un relais c'est un
représentant très récent du genre homo
mais il a des caractères extrêmement
primitif qui donne à penser que la
racine évolutive de aux monnaies les 10e
place à 2 et 5 millions d'années il est
à peu près aussi primitif que homo
habilis donc au monal est dit est connu
par beaucoup plus de matériel qu au mot
habilis il ya environ 1500 fossiles qui
ont été découverts il y en a encore plus
qui ont été retrouvés mais pas encore
publiés et on a des squelettes complets
des squelettes et des crânes complet de
hormonal est dit donc ce qui fait
vraiment de l'aumône à lady à quelque
chose d'exceptionnel c'est son âge
récent mais pour tout le reste c'est la
morphologie d'homo habilis il est
vraiment très très similaire à homo
habilis donc on voit notamment la taille
du cerveau qui compare très très bien
avec celle d'un australopithèque par
exemple donc 400 un australopithèque et
de l'ordre de 400 centimètres cubes
aumône à eddy est de l'ordre de 5
centimètres cubes au niveau de la boîte
crânienne
on a toujours un bourrelet sus orbitaire
mais par contre comme je le disais les
caractère plus humain de mona les dix se
trouvent au niveau de la mâchoire qui
est parabolique et aussi au niveau du
pied
donc le pied est définitivement
exactement comme celui d'un être humain
le tout les doigts en fait sont alignés
dans le même sens il n'ya plus de pouce
opposable chez homo naledi donc au monal
est dit était capable de marcher
exactement comme un être humain donc une
bipédie définitivement humaines chez
homo naledi tandis que sur la main eh
bien on a ce on a se poussent ici dont
qui évidemment opposable comme chez nous
mais le pouce est à peu près de la même
longueur que les autres doigts et ça ça
permet ce qu'on appelle en anglais le
precision grippe donc ça permet
d'attraper vraiment des objets avec
précision ça veut dire aussi que homo
naledi était probablement capable de
fabriquer des outils bien qu'on n'ait
pas encore retrouvé d'outils d'aumône à
lady ce qui est intéressant aussi avec
la main dont monae 10cc phalange
légèrement arqués qu'il a hérité quand
même
australopithèques donc qu'il a qui sont
enfin qui était du moins chez
australopithèques une adaptation pour se
déplacer dans les armes dont komona lady
donne une bonne image de ce à quoi
ressemblaient les premiers représentants
du genre homo ensuite ses représentants
du genre homo vont évoluer vers des
robes des espèces qu'on connaît bien
donc
homo erectus notamment donc au mans
effectué ses plus proches d'homo sapiens
par la taille du crâne on peut voir en
comparant au modèle est dit que le
volume crânien s est notamment très
visible quand on regarde vue de derrière
comme ça le volume crânien est beaucoup
plus gros chez homo erectus que chez
homo naledi donc c'est globalement une
augmentation par deux du volume crânien
donc là jusqu'à présent avec homo naledi
les australopithèques les parents trope
on avait un crâne qui était de l'ordre
de 400 centimètres cubes d'un volume de
4 centimètres cubes maintenant on passe
à 800 cm cube homo erectus en asie donc
l'homme de java est l'homme de pékin par
exemple peut atteindre jusqu'à 1000 cm
cube
donc c'est la branche asiatique d'homo
erectus qui avaient les plus gros volume
crânien donc ça c'est la branche
africaine d'homo erectus qu'on appelle
parfois aussi au moins gaster qui est
très identifiable par ces deux crêtes
qu'on voit sur le côté donc point
d'attaché toujours du muscle mastic
ateurs qu'on voit ici réduction de la
mâchoire donc vous voyez le petit museau
maintenant qui est vraiment beaucoup
plus petit que chez australopithèques us
museau beaucoup moins prononcé une phase
qui devient un peu plus humaine
de ce fait le bourlès orbitaire est
toujours présent mais le lézard cas de
gale elle par contre sont réduites
comparer encore une fois à
australopithecus africanus donc
réduction en général de la puissance
mastic à trice avec une réduction qui va
de pair avec une réduction de la taille
des dents dont vous voyez que les
molaires sont beaucoup plus petite que
celle que ses parents trope c'est très
évident quand on compare aux parents
trope donc la petite taille de ses
molaires
elle est essentiellement dû au fait que
homo erectus va apprendre à fabriquer
des outils ce qui va lui permettre de
découper sa nourriture avant de la deûle
à mastiquer donc le processus de
mastication va commencer
avant la mastication elle-même le
processus de découpage et de digestion
commence avec les mains et non plus avec
la bouche ce qui va de pair encore une
fois avec le pouce la taille du pouce
qui permet maintenant l'apprécient
jeunes grippe et on a aussi la
domestication du feu avec homo erectus
donc la domestication du feu est aussi
un phénomène qui permet de cuire la
nourriture et donc de près digéré la
nourriture et de pouvoir extraire
beaucoup plus de nutriments d'une même
quantité de bol alimentaire
donc c'est pour ça que là qu'on constate
cette réduction de la puissance mastic à
trice et de la taille des dans ce tout
ça va de pair avec le fait que désormais
homo erectus prédit gère sa nourriture
avec des outils et le feu donc comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure on retrouve homo
erectus en afrique sous la forme d' homo
ergaster mais on le retrouve aussi en
asie à partir de deux millions d'années
donc on a des outils en chine qui ont
2,1 millions d'années qui sont de la
culture des outils d'homo erectus
mais on a aussi des crânes et des
squelettes qui nous viennent de géorgie
et qui datent de 1,8 million d'années
tout cela a dit comment erectus a quitté
le berceau africain berceau africain qui
avait donc été occupée par toutes les
espèces qu'on a vu précédemment et
beaucoup d'autres quittent le berceau
africain et va conquérir l'eurasie donc
en europe
homo erectus va se retrouver isolée par
la glaciation et donner néandertal non
sans avoir donné avant les prêts
néandertaliens que son homo
heidelbergensis les homo heidelbergensis
et en asie il va donner la branche
asiatique d'homo erectus celle qui a un
gros cerveau est probablement mais on en
n'est pas totalement sûre l'homme de
denisova puisque l'homme de denisova
génétiquement très proche de l'homme de
néandertal on n'est pas vraiment sûr est
ce que ce serait pas plutôt des prêts
néandertaliens qui aurait donné l'homme
donneuse de denisova mais bref
en tout cas on est à peu près sûr on est
sûr de toute façon que erectus a quitté
le berceau africain
mais l'évolution de l'homme ne s'arrête
pas pour autant en afrique puisque en
afrique fini par évoluer donc au mot
rhodésienne 6 où l'homo sapiens
archaïque
on l'appelle par beaucoup beaucoup de
noms différents certaines personnes
appellent même et d'albert guen
his d'autres personnes préfèrent
l'appeler au mot et halle berry pour
nous on va dire homo sapiens archaïque
juste pour faire simple donc
homo sapiens pourquoi pas parce que
comme l'être humain son cerveau est très
très gros donc là on a un doublement
encore une fois de la taille de cerveau
donc on passe d'un cerveau de 8
centimètres cubes chez homo erectus un
cerveau de 1600 centimètres cubes donc
non seulement il est très gros mais il
est même plus gros que celui d'un homo
sapiens moderne qui est de 1400
centimètre cube en moyenne donc un
cerveau qui est très très gros donc qui
rentre totalement dans la gamme de
variation néanmoins de d'homo sapiens
donc voilà pourquoi il est appelé homo
sapiens maintenant pourquoi archaïque à
archaïque parce que toujours un petit
museau de la face n'est pas encore
complètement plate chez ceux chez ceux
homo sapiens archaïque
il a toujours un petit museau les dents
reste relativement massive le palais
paraboliques mais regardez comparer un
homo sapiens moderne la massivité des
dents indique toujours un régime
alimentaire quand même assez balèze il
faut savoir aussi que le haut niveau
régime alimentaire donc on avait les
australopithèques qui était plutôt
omnivore on a eu les la branche des
parentes robe qui a deux millions
d'années va devenir plus tôt herbivores
au mot le genre homo lui devient plutôt
carnivores donc omnivore attendant ce
carnivore
ce qui va aussi influencé l'évolution
des dents et ce qui va le rendre
archaïque aussi par rapport à homo
sapiens anatomiquement modernes ça va
être ce bourg les sur orbite à vous
voyez le bourrelet sur son orbite air
est extrêmement effet réduit entre les
deux orbites quand même donc entre les
deux
les deux trous pour les yeux vous voyez
qu'il est relativement réduit alors ça
ça lui donne du coup ce regard un peu
vénère et il a pas l'air content c'est
très typique d'un homo sapiens archaïque
et des roulements et d'albert gagnent
six européens
comparez homo sapiens qui lui a plutôt
l'air triste
voilà mais ça c'est dû au fait que vous
avez ces deux bords les suces orbitaire
qui sont maintenant isolé puisqu'il n'y
a plus vraiment de bourg les suces
orbitaire entre les deux donc c'est le
preuve la première étape vers la
réduction du bourrelet su solitaire la
2e étape vers la disparition du
bourrelet sus orbitaire étant le
développement du cortex préfrontal qui
va venir recouvrir le boulaire les suces
orbitaire est donné ce qu'on voit chez
homo sapiens donc le bourhis us
orbitaire est pas complètement parti
chez homo sapiens il est toujours là
mais il est recouvert par le cortex
préfrontal les représentants les plus
anciens d'homo sapiens archaïque on les
retrouve à partir de 300 mille ans et
jusqu'à et 160 mille ans en afrique
manque 300 mille ans et le crâne de
djebel et route qui est très similaire à
celui là une rebours les suces orbitaire
boîte crânienne aussi relativement ovale
contrairement à nos sa classe moderne
qui a une boîte crânienne plutôt
arrondies et puis évidemment le petit
museau donc petit museau tout ça va
disparaître chez homo sapiens moderne
qui apparaît entre 200000 et 120 mille
ans
deux cent mille d'après les données
génétiques 120000 d'après les données
paléontologiques donc là on a la forme
finale du crâne d'un d'homo sapiens
anatomiquement modernes disparition du
bourrelet sus orbitaire développement du
lobe frontal crâne de forme arrondie et
non plus ovale comme chez néandertal ou
chez delberghe m6 dentition réduite
palais paraboliques le regard triste
très important et last but not least au
niveau de la mâchoire
vous allez avoir le petit menton voilà
le petit menton projeter vers l'avant
qu'on le retrouve chez aucun autre grand
singe donc si je prends mais là j'ai pas
j'ai pas de mâchoire pour homo
heidelbergensis mai et d'albert gagnent
6 et néandertal sont exactement comme
sediba de ce point de vue là donc il
n'ya pas de menton voyez le menton et
fuyant il part vers l'arrière au lieu de
faire ce petit rebond vers
avant qu'on voit et qui est typique
d'homo sapiens donc ça c'est aussi un
caractère très très typique d'homo
sapiens donc voilà si vous êtes à la
recherche d'un chaînon manquant et bien
ils sont tous là on a on a absolument
tout la série de transformations qui
mène d'un grand singe enfin d'un singe
un grand singe à un homininés primitif
est tout ce qui nous sépare de cette
mine et primitive toute la gamme de
variation est recouverte par le registre
fossile donc au final le de tous et
chaînon manquant ben on pourrait dire
qu'il ne manque aucun